il y a un gros changement chez Samsung
il y a de nouveaux écrans qui vont
arriver alors on connaissait les écrans
qui se payaient de Samsung vous savez
sur le Samsung Galaxy Z flip Z fold et
compagnie on les connaît mais cette
fois-ci en plus de ça ils viennent
s'enrouler ils peuvent à la fois se
plier et son rouler mais ils peuvent
aussi uniquement s'enrouler d'un côté
mais également de côté ça ouvre beaucoup
de perspectives ça permet de voir là où
on va aller sur les smartphones mais pas
uniquement sur les smartphones je vais
vous détailler tout ça j'ai tout vous
expliquer c'est extrêmement passionnant
ça permet de voir là où on va aller
est-ce que vous êtes prêt allez on y va
[Musique]
les écrans qui se plie on connaît les
écrans qui sont rouges on connaît un peu
mais il y a pas réellement de produits
sur le marché actuellement sauf sur le
oppo et on se bouffer la référence je
vous avais déjà présenté il y a 2 ans me
semble-t-il c'est à dire un smartphone
avec un écran qui vient sans rouler et
se dérouler alors au pot nous la
présenter c'était uniquement un
prototype mais ça devrait arriver les
usages arrivent petit à petit pourquoi
parce qu'on veut de la modularité c'est
très bien d'avoir un smartphone comme ça
qui s'ouvre ce terme on est content mais
on veut des smartphones qui vont être
totalement modulaires et on comprend
notamment le succès du Samsung Galaxy Z
flip 4 et zelflip 3 sur les smartphones
qu'on vient rétrécir qui prennent moins
d'encombrement avec un grand écran qui
est vachement agréable ça permet
effectivement d'avoir une plus compact
dans la poche plutôt qu'avoir un énorme
truc qui dépasse donc ça c'est vachement
cool sauf que il y a plein de techno qui
arrivent Samsung est le premier avoir
des gainé avec son pliable mais
l'enroulable existe également donc ça
permet d'ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives et justement là oh ces 2023
Samsung a présenté de nouvelles
technologies alors regardez je vous
montre on est directement sur leur news
room sur leur site et nous le montre ils
viennent présenter le futur de l'Oly oui
parce que Lola c'est une très grosse
techno que maîtrise ça me saoule ça
permet d'avoir des dalles qui se plient
parce qu'on a des technologies qui sont
extrêmement fines alors regardez c'est
pas bien d'avoir un côté qui se plie
comme ce qu'on connaît sur le Samsung
Galaxy Z fold ou Z flip 4 3 et autre
génération mais également toute une
partie qui vient s'enrouler et se
dérouler ici et ça c'est génial parce
que effectivement là où un smartphone va
pouvoir uniquement s'ouvrir cette fermer
c'est-à-dire très très bien il va
pouvoir s'agrandir davantage en
s'enroulant alors vous pouvez avoir le
choix entre plusieurs combinaisons soit
le smartphone il est complètement fermé
et vous avez une dalle classique ouverte
en grand ça vous fait un très grand
smartphone comme sur le Z fold 4 ça
marche très bien mais lorsque vous
voulez davantage ouvrir votre smartphone
et bien vous pouvez venir le dérouler ça
vous fait un superbe écran alors ça ça
va être vachement cool pour plusieurs
usages si on reste uniquement basé tout
de suite sur le smartphone ça va être
super pour faire du multitâche pour voir
encore mieux ses photos en grand pour
pouvoir encore mieux regarder ces films
et ses séries pour aller encore plus
loin au niveau du gaming alors pour le
gaming il va falloir que les éditeurs
viennent s'adapter parce que ça c'est
quand même de très grandes dalles et
qu'aujourd'hui je suis pas convaincu que
les éditeurs soient prêts mais ça monte
de nouveaux usages et je trouve ça
génial c'est le flex hybride c'est le
nom qu'a donné Samsung ici à cette dalle
et en plus de ça ils viennent s'appuyer
sur leur technologie
qd OLED alors je vous fais un petit
retour en arrière on revient début 2022
ces 2022 Samsung présenté en petit
comité le qd OLED alors si vous
connaissez les technologies de Samsung
jusqu'à présent c'était sur du cul LED
au niveau de l'oral ils avaient
effectivement du OLED et de la molette
sur les smartphones mais sur les télés
c'était du cul Lady ils sont arrivés
avec le qd au lait dans le cul des OLED
c'est quoi le cul des OLED en fait une
dalle OLED on connaît classique très
bien avec des pixels auto et missive bon
ok on passe un peu l'idée de la techno
du OLED derrière mais en plus de ça ils
viennent rajouter un canton nous donne
devant qui va améliorer les couleurs et
qui va donner un peu plus de contraste
donc des images qui sont vachement mieux
et ils l'ont amélioré en 2023 avec plus
de luminosité bref une dalle qui est
totalement optimisée ça c'est vachement
cool petit aparté mais petite guillemets
là d'ailleurs je vous ai montré sur les
short je sais pas si vous avez regardé
sur Youtube short sur les Tik Tok et
Instagram Real c'est compagnie je vous
ai une techno qui vient pas ici de
Samsung qui vient de TCL où on va venir
imprimer sur les écrans imprimer des
écrans voilà c'est une nouvelle techno
qui arrive dans les années d'ici
peut-être 3-4 ans donc je pense que
Samsung va y arriver ils sont peut-être
déjà d'ailleurs en train de travailler
dessus aujourd'hui mais voyez les techno
évoluent énormément donc revenons à
notre histoire vous avez effectivement
toute cette partie là avec cet écran qui
vient se plier d'un côté et de l'autre
et ce qui est super intéressant ce que
lui alors je vais vous éviter tout
l'article en anglais on va aller
directement aux parties qui nous
intéresse dédale effectivement que sont
toutes les tailles des petites des
moyennes et des grandes qui permettent
de combiner gagna à la fois du pliable
et de l'enroulable ça je vous ai
expliqué le QDO LED je vous ai expliqué
effectivement qui va porter plus de
luminosité des images plus réalistes
effectivement avec les couleurs et
notamment de meilleurs contrastes mais
en plus de ça il vient de travailler
avec de l'intelligence artificielle et
un algorithme il vous en parle c'est
l'intelligence ai qui permettra de venir
totalement optimiser votre image tu vas
venir analyser votre image ça c'est
vachement chouette mais on nous parle
effectivement et bien du futur des smart
mobile devices slidable c'est-à-dire
effectivement ce qui vient s'enrouler se
dérouler ici c'est une toute nouvelle
techno c'est très chouette et ça permet
notamment de regarder sur le flexible et
moyen de regarder des vidéos avec un
écran 10,5 pouces avec un ratio 4/3 et
lorsque vous venez dérouler la partie
vous allez carrément en 12,4 pouces avec
un ratio 16/10 je trouve ça super
intéressant donc là regardez il vous le
montre ouvert comme ça et vous le montre
un peu fermé pour vous puissiez voir que
ça donne l'impression d'avoir une
imprimante vous voyez ou un scanner un
papier posé comme ça comme la photo est
faite c'est assez marrant et d'ailleurs
ce qui est super intéressant regardez il
vous le marque ici on va aller plutôt
sur des prototypes de futurs ordinateurs
alors c'est vrai qu'on reconnaît cette
techno notamment au niveau des
smartphones et je vous le dis pour
réduire l'encombrement ou pour venir
augmenter les tailles d'écran mais sur
les ordinateurs c'est extrêmement malin
alors c'est Asus qui a présenté il y a
pas longtemps c'est un ordinateur qui
vient se plier et déplier pourquoi parce
que on va gagner effectivement en
compacité et lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous
avez un très très grand écran on peut
pour autant venir le plier en deux et
poser un vrai clavier physique sur la
partie d'écran du bas du coup tout le
contenu va rester sur l'écran du haut
c'est assez modulaire c'est modulable
c'est pratique on peut également
l'ouvrir l'utiliser comme un petit
chevalet et avoir son écran devant vous
regardez des films à des séries encore
je trouve ça pratique une fois de plus
c'est pas mais de montrer la modularité
mais imaginez la même idée vous avez un
ordinateur qui vient se plier et qui à
la fois vient s'ouvrir d'un côté
pourquoi pas de l'autre et là c'est ce
qui nous montre c'est cette nouvelle
techno c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
slideable flex duet qui vient à la fois
s'ouvrir d'un côté et à la fois de
l'autre alors imaginez effectivement là
vous avez un écran alors je sais pas si
vous marquez les dimensions et après on
est sur les télés on s'en fout un peu là
on part effectivement de 13 ou 14 pouces
fermées et on va jusqu'à 17,3 pouces
ouverts le truc est super cool derrière
c'est une fois de plus projetez-vous
dans l'idée d'avoir un ordinateur un
ordinateur avec un PC un peu pas un PC
qui est le format peut-être plus de
niveau de la modularité mais j'aime bien
prendre l'exemple du PC pliable d'Asus
pourquoi et bien parce que pourri très
bien avoir votre PC qui se plie et une
fois déplié on pourrait venir ouvrir
d'un côté et de l'autre et ça vous
ferait un énorme écran donc on rentre
vraiment dans des airs de modularité
peut-être pas pour tous les produits
peut-être pas pour tous les
constructeurs mais en tout cas ça va
venir s'élargir et là où il vous le
montre effectivement pour tout ce qui va
être gaming pour regarder des films des
séries pour aussi le multitâche vous
allez la voir il parle aussi
effectivement ici d'automobile donc on
peut imaginer venir plier déplier
agrandir tous des écrans qu'on va
retrouver dans l'automobile donc Samsung
en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que vous avez Samsung l'entité Samsung
qui a beaucoup de parties de filiales
sous elle vous avez notamment Samsung
électronique ce qui fabrique les
smartphones les tablettes les
ordinateurs que vous connaissez mais
c'est une entité parmi d'autres vous
avez Samsung display qui eux conçoivent
fabrique des écrans et qui se les
vendent à eux-mêmes ça me saoule
électronique pour fabriquer leurs écrans
de smartphone autre et compagnie mais
également à d'autres marques d'autres
constructeurs qui vont intégrer leur
dalle à molette directement dans leur
smartphone mais également au niveau des
ordinateurs donc ça vous voyez c'est
super intéressant de voir que ces techno
qu'il maîtrisent vont permettre
d'arriver sur de nouveaux produits et de
nouveaux usages bon et après ils vous
ont fait tout un petit truc au niveau
des télés avec le nouveau
qd OLED 2023 je pense qu'on reparlera de
qd au lait de cette année que ce sont
des moniteurs des téléviseurs et
compagnies bref je vous ai fait aussi
une petite vidéo sur Youtube shirts Tik
Tok et Instagram real allez jeter un
coup d’œil abonnez-vous d'ailleurs si
vous voulez pas comme ça vous saurez
tout de l'actu tech et ça c'est chouette
parce qu'il y a plein de petits formats
que je vais faire en plus sur Tik Tok à
starrills et puis en YouTube short parce
que je vais pas forcément mettre sur une
vidéo plus longue plein de petites
innovations que je suis venu capter que
ce soit sur un comme le ces il y a pas
longtemps ou des petites nouveautés dont
je viens vous parler comme ça ça c'est
super chouette donc voyez il y a tout ça
qui est génial et ça permet vraiment
d'attrapercevoir donc dites-moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que vous aimez
l'idée d'un smartphone qui se plier
est-ce que vous avez peut-être déjà
acheté un smartphone qui se plie chez
Samsung est-ce que pour autant l'idée de
l'enroulable c'est un truc qui vous
aille parce que vous vous verriez avoir
quelque chose qui s'enroule comme ça
est-ce que vous voyez vraiment l'intérêt
de l'enroulable et puis pourquoi pas
venir combiner l'enroulable le pliable
et puis l'idée d'aller encore plus loin
sur un PC qui vient s'enrouler d'un côté
et l'autre est-ce que vous voyez
vraiment l'intérêt moi je me pose la
question vous voyez là tout de suite je
suis sur mon mon mac est-ce que j'ai
envie qu'il y a une partie qui vient de
s'ouvrir là ça me ferait un énorme écran
imaginez j'en sais rien moi vous avez un
13 pouces et votre 13 pouces vous
l'agrandissez et vous arrivez sur un
espèce de format un peu sur un 15 16
peut-être même 17 pouces alors qu'il
sera pas extrêmement parce qu'on va
venir l'enrouler sur les côtés pas
forcément le dérouler sur le haut sinon
il y a un moment il y a une limite
physique ça marchera plus mais imaginez
que ça vienne s'ouvrir sur les côtés
c'est vachement bien pour j'en sais rien
moi je prends un streamer par exemple
moi je prends pour mon job si un moment
j'ai envie de venir streamer et bien
j'aime bien avoir mon Obs d'un côté
avoir le de l'autre côté pour avoir
d'autres vidéos et si je peux partager
ça sur mon écran avec différentes
fenêtres je trouve ça juste génial et le
faire aujourd'hui sur un moniteur 16
pouces c'est cool mais c'est pas assez
donc l'idée que ça vient de s'ouvrir
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs je vous ai
montré une petite techno qui était
vachement intéressante que l'autre jour
au CES c'est des extensions pour
ordinateur où vous avez des petits
ajouts d'écran sur le côté et ça se
branche directement sur les ports usb-c
de votre PC je trouve ça c'est malin
donc l'idée d'avoir un écran qui vient
s'ouvrir comme ça sur un PC ça va éviter
d'avoir ses ados et ça évitera d'avoir
des grands moniteurs à droite à gauche
et ça porte vraiment modularité en
flexibilité en mobilité je trouve ça une
fois de plus extrêmement cool donc
dites-moi vous ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires est-ce que vous
auriez envie d'avoir un smartphone qui
explique qui s'enroule qui se déplie on
peut l'imaginer également sur des
tablettes ça peut être très pratique sur
des ordinateurs et puis bien évidemment
Samsung nous le dit ici sur de
l'automobile je trouve ça dingue dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas dans
les commentaires et puis quand des
produits comme ça a fini arriveront on
en parlera bien évidemment ici donc
ensuite pas de plus à bien vous abonner
je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et
à très bientôt pour plus d'actu tech des
bisous Ciao
[Musique]